okay the latest
development in the joe rogan spotify
controversy is that the ceo of the
trump-affiliated right-wing social media
platform rumble
has offered rogan 100
million dollars to leave spotify and to
bring his show
to rumble there's a very short and
straightforward reuters report about
this rogan gets 100 million dollar offer
from trump-affiliated site rumble rumble
inc a youtube style website popular
among us conservatives has offered joe
rogan 100 million dollars over four
years for all his shows
days after the podcaster apologized for
using racial slurs in his content rogan
is facing backlash for covet
misinformation on his program hosted on
spotify
neil young and joni mitchell pulled
their content from the platform the
incidents prompted spotify to add a
content advisory to any episode
featuring discussion of covet as
scientists and medical professionals
urged the platform to prevent rogan from
spreading falsehoods so this
ceo um wrote to rogan chris pavlovsky is
the ceo of rumble and wrote dear joe we
stand with you your guests and your
legion of fans and desire for real
conversation so we'd like to offer you
100 million reasons to make the world a
better place how about you bring all
your shows to rumble both old and new
with no
censorship for 100 million bucks over
four years this is our chance to save
the world and yes this is totally legit
so there's a couple different things
here i think that that are important to
talk about
um first and foremost
there's a reality that more than likely
joe rogan can't just do this because
he's under contract with spotify if
spotify pulled
his show
uh they'd probably still have to pay him
uh even if they released him from the
contract they might still have to give
him something if he had some other thing
you know
we don't know the exact details of the
contract so it's it's like an offer
rumble can make
that's very unlikely to become a real
thing because of how these contracts
tend to work and i say that without
actually having looked at joe rogan's
contract but
my
my concern here is as follows and many
of you know that number one i've been on
rogan's program twice
um and when i was on
no topic was off limits and
i said whatever i wanted to and rogan
seemed completely open to listening to
what i had to say and and in a serious
you know and genuine way
and
since then
i have not held back at criticizing joe
rogan when he has
engaged in spreading covet
disinformation either through things he
says or things his guests say that
remain unchallenged we lampooned uh his
bizarre interview with jordan peterson
like i've i've not held back at all i
know that some of my
progressive um
uh
cohor some of some parts elements of my
progressive cohort
have held back
and i don't know why it might be
they don't want to maybe lose future
access to rogan like as i've said
he may have no idea about the things
i've been saying and he might have me
back on if i said hey i'm going to be
down in austin and i'd love to be on or
he might never speak to me again i have
no idea i've not exchanged any messages
with rogan for a while i just call it
like i see it and uh on on the recent
stuff
i do think
that the things that are being uncovered
that rogan said
are absolutely horrible and disgusting
and i also believe that his apology was
sincere to the extent that
i don't
believe
that deep down
he is
trying to spread disinformation i think
he gets lulled into it through something
that we might call
kind of like audience capture and guest
capture
the circle that he's in and it's like
you know there's people who are going to
say this is too harsh to critique and
people who will say i'm being too easy
on rogan i think the reality is that
while rogan has shown himself to be
significantly open-minded for a long
time
uh rogan is in a circle that is very
culturally conservative and that
culturally conservative circle includes
um
race-based jokes that i find completely
gross
and it all it also includes certain
ideology when it comes to government
regulation and covid and the like i mean
the guy has said
he has seen
the wacky texas governor greg abbott
personally since he has moved to texas
abbott's completely out of his mind and
rogan from what i've heard acts like
greg abbott is a reasonable normal
person to be listening to listening to
so there's both
the audience of rogan skews culturally
conservative
um and in addition to that he's in these
culturally conservative circles which
makes it so that he has more right-wing
guests than left-wing guests now there's
a list that has been spreading of
rogan's right wing guests versus left
wing and the right wing list is much
longer the right wing list is much
longer at the same time there were some
notable people missing from the left
wing guests that he has had on me for
example i wasn't on that list i've been
on twice so i think with all of these no
one thing really tells us everything
about this story but the real concern i
have is he's already
in a sort of right-wing echo chamber
because he has gone to texas and he's
hanging out with greg abbott and all
these other people uh because he is
getting the most positive feedback from
the right wing who says his racial
comments are perfectly fine his coveted
comments are perfectly fine and so the
concern is it's only gonna get worse
and i think it's unlikely
that um
spotify is going to drop him at this
point in time and from a very practical
perspective one of the worst things i
can imagine
is the show just getting more right wing
that that seems like it would be a bad
thing so uh that's my general
perspective on this at this point in
time
uh the things that that rogan has said
are completely indefensible and he
doesn't seem to be defending them and
there's questions as to whether the
apology is sincere or not i mean of
course that question can sort of always
be asked uh but um at this point the the
worst thing given the size of his
podcast is for it to become more of a
right-wing echo chamber he should be
held to what he said he would do
which is to have more people on
with views based on
the accepted science
on covid and and he should be held to
that period end of story
i want to introduce you to emmy the
world's first instant ramen that is low
carb high protein and 100
plant based each serving of imi
is packed with 21 grams of protein
19 grams of fiber has only five net
carbs works for keto diets and 35
percent less sodium than traditional
ramen brands i've been making it at home
just like any instant ramen it's ready
in just a few minutes you can use the
microwave you can use the stovetop you
really can't beat the convenience but
with imme you can feel good about the
ramen you're eating because of all the
fiber the lower sodium and it is
plant-based which i love even though i'm
not vegan or vegetarian but the best
part is
it's so well packaged it comes in
flavors like spicy beef
tom yum shrimp
black garlic chicken the taste and the
quality of the ingredients really sets
it apart from any other instant ramen
i've had and emmy is giving my audience
five dollars off a variety pack when you
go to emmyeats.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
the link is down below